liebe kolleginnen und kollegen herzlich
willkommen in der bundespressekonferenz
ein brief auch an die fotografin und
fotografen die ich bitten würde langsam
hier vorne etwas platz zu machen
und wir sprechen heute wieder über die
aktuelle pandemische lage in sehr
bedrückenden zeiten tagen unter etwas
anderen vorzeichen
ich möchte dennoch zuallererst
bundesgesundheitsminister presse dr karl
lauterbach
begrüßen den präsident des robert koch
instituts professor doktor luther wieder
und den vorstandsvorsitzenden der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung dr
andreas gassen hat sich so kommen sie
alle nachdem die pressekonferenz live
übertragen wird noch kurz ein paar
eingehende worte anfangs worte zu
unserer institutionen die
bundespressekonferenz
regierungsunabhängig eine
selbstorganisation von größeren wissen
die vier pressekonferenzen
veranstalten damit unsere mitglieder und
die mitglieder auch das vereins der
ausländischen presse fragen stellen
können diese auch beantwortet bekommen
wir begrenzen diese pressekonferenz auf
eine stunde wir haben heute auch wieder
eine abschlusspressekonferenz
deswegen halten wir das zeitfenster fest
ein und die frage regeln sind ihnen an
ihm bekannt so viel für meine heutige
staaten inhaltlich zusammen vielen dank
frau wolff vielen dank für die
gelegenheit hier in ihrem haus wieder
gast sein zu dürfen
ich möchte zunächst unter worte zur
invasion in der ukraine
vortragen ich finde die vorgänge
bestürzend und
in jeder hinsicht traurig
hier hat jemand in verbrecherischer art
nämlich werden mir putin das völkerrecht
gebrochen
und zieht damit aufmerksamkeit auf sich
und gefährdet menschen in einer
situation wo wir noch mitten in der
hohen abhang sind und viele andere
wichtige aufgaben vor uns haben die welt
hat wirklich besseres zu tun als sich
mit den großmacht fantasien von putin zu
beschäftigen wir müssen den klimawandel
bekämpfen wir müssen die wir kämpfen wir
müssen neue pannen verhindern
ich finde es einfach schlicht und
ergreifend bestürzend narzisstisch und
in keiner weise akzeptabel
und wir tun insbesondere die kinder leid
die in diesen tagen in der ukraine
leiden müssen die kinder wären also kind
hat unterbrochen wird und die hier in
angst und terror um das eigene leben und
das leben ihrer eltern fürchten müssen
das ist etwas was ein kind verdient was
einfach schlicht furchtbar ist und da
ist man mitgefühl insbesondere den
betroffenen kindern aber nicht nur den
kindern und ich hoffe dass dieser krieg
bald zu ende sein wird von niemandem
gebraucht er schadet allen und er ist in
keiner weise
akzeptabel sei wie gesagt die an
verbrecherisch eine verbrecherische
verletzung des völkerrechtes
möglicherweise so scheint es mir
zumindest auch zum teil vermittelt durch
narzisstische geltungsbedürfnis die
nicht hinnehmbar sind ich komme
eigentlich ein pandemie wir müssen
vorsichtig sein dass wir nicht glauben
die pandemie sei vorbei das ist sie
nicht wir haben also sero fallzahlen die
wir möglicherweise sogar unterschätzen
die tatsächliche zahl könnte noch höher
sein wir haben eine situation wo wir pro
tag 200 bis 300 todesfälle haben ich
habe ja selbst immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen dass man also die verläufe
bei der omicron variante nicht
unterschätzen darf sehr häufig dauern
die verläufe bei schwerem verlauf länger
aber dann kommt es dann nach langem
verlauf doch noch zum tod und das ist
daher etwas was wir nicht falsch
einschätzen dürfen wir haben moment mit
die höchsten todeszahlen die wir in den
letzten monaten gehabt haben und wir
sind auch noch nicht sicher über den
berg was die zahlen angeht
richtig ist dass wir also dem
scheitelpunkt erreicht haben das hat
mich auch genau so berechnet mit dem
modell des robert-koch-institutes mitte
februar ist es aber eine neue variante
der umgekommen also eine sub variante
der omicron variante für uns
problematisch die bezahlvariante die
derzeit etwa 16 17 prozent aller fälle
in deutschland ausmachen scheint aber in
großen städten wie zb in köln in einigen
labor und bereits 25 prozent ausmacht
und die in dänemark und auch in
südafrika natürlich an viel größeren
anteil nachher gehabt hat wir wissen
dass diese variante an stecke da ist von
dem was wir bisher wissen scheint sie
nicht schwerer zu verlaufen aber wenn
sie alleine ansteckend da ist dann wurde
das dazu führen können dass wir
möglicherweise wieder wenn wir jetzt
nicht vorsichtig sind steigende
fallzahlen bekommen das wir bei der
sterblichkeit über die ich eben gerade
gesprochen habe niemand daher noch
einmal meine warnung mein appell an die
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten der länder auf
keinen fall bei dem lockerungen und über
das hinwegzugehen was wir beschlossen
haben denn sonst ist ein schwerer
rückfall hier nicht ausgeschlossen und
anderen solchen rückfall wollen wir
derzeit nicht erleben und wir müssen
also war er vorbereitet zahlen die
beschlüsse der ministerpräsident
konferenz sind gut und richtig in den
drei stufen aber eine beschleunigung der
öffnung dafür haben wir überhaupt keine
spielräume
wir haben im moment also eine wichtige
gesetzgeberische aufgabe vor uns also
infektionsschutzgesetz muss neu
geschrieben werden daran arbeite ich im
wesentlichen
dem kollegen buschmann von der fdp
zusammen in der regierung und also auch
bei aber auch mit anderen
regierungsmitgliedern ich würde hier
noch klar sagen dass ich für eine
version des infektionsschutzgesetzes
arbeitet mit der man später auch
arbeiten kann ich später auch
tatsächlich uns hier möglichkeiten gibt
zu diesen möglichkeiten also gehört
nicht nur die feststellung des genesenen
status oder es im status sondern man
muss auch ganz klassische schutzkonzepte
umsetzen können dazu zählen
abstandsgebot
kontakt beschränkungen hygiene konzepte
und auch also
andere maßnahmen wie zum beispiel der
besondere schutz von pflegeheimen oder
krankenhäusern und einrichtungen und
darüber hinausgehende regeln zu hotspots
das ist was nicht mehr unter anderem
solchen gesetz vorstelle dann kann man
damit arbeiten also ein großer teil
dieser maßnahmen wurde dann durch die
landesparlamente im bedarfsfall
beschlossen wir werden aber dann gut
vorbereitet gut vorbereitet für
rückfälle in den nächsten monaten
sollten sie kommen und insbesondere
wären wir gut vorbereitet auch für den
herbst wo ich mit neuen bällen rechnen
somit muss an die substanz haltiges
infektionsschutzgesetz träger gesetz
muss vorgelegt werden da haben wir sehr
intensiv gearbeitet und ich vertrete da
tatsächlich die vorsichtige wusste
position die welle ist nicht gebrochen
in der wir sind heuer werden können
kommen wir brauchen etwas womit man dann
sofort reagieren kann wir werden im
rahmen der also reform des
infektionsschutzgesetzes auch das
vereinsrecht für den genesenen status
und also für den impfstatus ändern das
habe ich ja hier schon vorgetragen dass
es auch mit herrn wieder abgesprochen
wir sind da nicht also im dissenz dass
das wieder also einer rechtsverordnung
gesetzgebung geld wird durch den
bundesminister also dass wir also auch
anerkennen dass es sich bei diesen
beschlüssen sehr oft um politische
beschlüsse haben das sind formal
natürlich technische beschlüsse wer ist
genesen wird es nicht genießen aber
natürlich das auch immer also beschluss
damit
weitestgehenden politischen konsequenzen
daher also möchte ich das also aus
minister wieder machen wir in dem
zusammenhang auch noch einmal darauf
hinweisen dass die inhaltliche
positionierung des
robert-koch-institutes von herrn wieder
vorgetragen dass eine genießen den
status also auf 90 tage begrenzt sein
muss dass diese entscheidung richtig war
und auch von mir mitgetragen wird der in
der genesenen status also von 180 tagen
trägt einfach nicht der tatsache
rechnung dass man sich zum beispiel bei
der omicron variante mit der b12
variante infizieren kann wenn man die
baa1 variante gerade gehabt hat mehr
muss ich nicht sagen oder vor der data
variante hat man kaum schutz wenn man
von der comic-con variante sich also
erholt hat somit also damit dass noch
mal klargestellt ist die 90 tage die ja
wieder vorgetragen hatte für das robert
koch institut sind in der sache richtig
dass hat daher auch nichts damit zu tun
dass wir jetzt diese rechts verweise
verändern aber ende also verweis ordnung
das sind hoch politische beschlüsse
muster minister stehen und das kann man
nicht abgeschoben werden die an das
robert-koch-institut das
paul-ehrlich-institut lassen sie mich
noch darauf hinweisen ich habe häufig
das jetzt also vor uns liegen freedom
day das also das ende der pandemie in
deutschland also unmittelbar zu erwarten
sei dass es eine einschätzung die ich
ausdrücklich nicht teile ich gehe davon
aus dass ich also dass corona virus vom
freedom de gehen wir feiern würden nicht
beeindrucken lässt in keiner weise
beeindrucken lässt das ist einfach
weitergehen würde und so daher ist an
frieden aus meiner sicht nicht
ungefährlich weil er gibt uns eine
sicherheit die wir nicht haben ich will
ganz zum schluss noch einmal darauf
hinweisen
wieso müssen wir eigentlich hier noch
immer vorsichtig sein und will in
ländern wie dänemark beispielsweise
england in frankreich ist zum teil schon
viel mehr möglich wo andy
mellitus fern die vorgehensweise dieser
länder zu kritisieren aber der
entscheidende unterschied ist eben dass
wir eine viel höhere zahl von
ungeimpften haben in der altersgruppe
über 60 das ist der unterschied
beispielsweise also sind in dänemark
also wenn man jetzt die doppelte impfung
heranzieht fast 100 prozent der menschen
über 60 sind geimpft der allergrößte
teil ist gewusst hat dass ich dann
natürlich mit anderen regeln arbeiten
kann als wenn ich eine mittlere aber
wenn ich zwischen zehn und zwölf prozent
ganz ungeimpfte über 60 habe das ist
klar und das muss man immer vom ende her
denken selbst länder wie beispielsweise
england wo man noch zwei prozent
ungeimpfte vermutet in der altersgruppe
der über 60-jährigen wir hätten dann im
vergleich fünf bis sechs mal so viele
und wenn ich fünf bis sechsmal so viele
gefährdete menschen habe dann kommen
ganz andere zahlen zusammen daher sind
wir einfach nicht mit diesen ländern
vergleichbar deutschland muss einen
sonderweg gehen weil wir eine
sondersituation haben die
sondersituation darf man nicht vergessen
all diejenigen die sagen
lernen doch wo ich gehöre dass jeden tag
lerne doch von england lernen doch wieso
lernen werde ich von dänemark und weiter
wir können von dänemark und von england
können wir viel lernen man kann nicht
lernen wie wir unsere über 60 jährigen
schützen weil diese gibt es dort nicht
als ungeimpfte in dem maße darauf will
ich noch einmal ausdrücklich hinweisen
und zur impfkampagne die also sich jetzt
nur noch schleppend also bewegt weil
viele menschen glauben dass also die
omikron variante nicht so gefährlich ist
eine fehleinschätzung oder menschen
glauben dass man demnächst omikron wie
impfstoffe
nehmen sollte für die weiteren impfungen
die noch nicht da sind oder
dass die ganz allgemein vorbei das führt
ja alles dazu dass viel weniger
impfbereitschaft also da ist als wir
benötigen darüber denken wir derzeit
sehr intensiv in meinem haus nach liebe
die impfbereitschaft wieder erhöhen
können ich will die ausdrücklich darauf
hinweisen dass gerade die omikron
infizierten wenig schutz haben wenn sie
nicht zusätzlich geld sind aber einen
sehr hohen schutz haben wenn sie auch
nur eine einzige zusätzliche impfung
haben daher appelliere ich auch an alle
von ikon infizierten der hre jetzt
moment viele dass sie sich zumindest
einmal zusätzlich impfen lassen um einen
vollständigen impfschutz zu erreichen so
viel von meiner seite ich freue mich
dass heute
geht das wort zurück anfangen vielen
dank herr lauterbach bis hierher wir
machen unbedingt arbeiter irgendeinen
morgen zusammen meine damen die
fallzahlen gehen langsam aber stetig
weiter zurück und das ist in fast allen
bundesländern so aber die fallzahlen
sind natürlich immer noch auf einem sehr
hohen niveau das sind gute nachrichten
sie zeigen dass sich die
infektionsschutz maßnahmen lohnen und
sie zeigen auch dass impfungen und
maßnahmen wirken und das virus wird auch
immer weiter zurückgedrängt so dass auch
eine schrittweise und kontrollierte
rücknahme von maßnahmen möglich ist auch
haben wir keine so hohen sterbezahlen
wie wir das in anderen ländern sehen
momentan aber schauen wir uns die
situation einmal etwas genauer an den
meldedaten zufolge haben sich seit
beginn der omicron welle in deutschland
rund fünf millionen menschen mit saas
kopf 2 infiziert das bedeutet aber auch
selbst wenn die fallzahlen genauso rasch
zurückgehen wie sie an gestiegen sind
während sich in den kommenden wochen
noch einmal genauso viele menschen
infizieren durch die zunehmende
zirkulation der omicron sub linie baa2
könnte das aber auch noch länger dauern
und noch mehr menschen betreffen weil
sich diese zucchini tatsächlich noch
leichter verbreitet als baa1 das heißt
wir müssen die situation weiterhin
wirklich ernst nehmen wenn man sich die
aktuellen daten anschaut dann wird auch
deutlich dass vor allem ältere menschen
nach wie vor gefährdet sind daher ist
lausig das lka absolut essentiell dass
risikogruppen wie ältere und chronisch
kranke weiterhin besonders geschützt
werden wir sehen zb das mit den menschen
über 80 die sieben tage incidents also
entgegen dem allgemeinen trend wieder
ansteigt und wir sehen auch dass
ausbrüche in altenheim wieder zunehmen
auch die hospitalisierung since it ends
steigt vor allen dingen bei den älteren
deutlich an zur zeit werden immer noch
rund
2300 cupid 19 patienten und patientinnen
auf intensivstation behandelt und auch
da sind fast drei viertel über 60 jahre
alt auch bei den todesfällen sehen wir
zurzeit keinen rückgang im gegenteil in
den letzten beiden wochen sind die
zahlen sogar wieder etwas angestiegen
auch wenn wir unter dem niveau der del
tabelle bleiben auch das alles müssen
wir im blick haben um das noch einmal
deutlich zu sagen ja wir sind auf einem
guten weg aber wir müssen noch einige
wochen weiter aufeinander aufpassen und
uns impfen lassen eine vollständige
impfung und vor allem die
auffrischimpfung schützen sehr gut vor
schweren verläufen und auch todesfällen
auch gerade bei den älteren eine
vollständige impfung kann aber offenbar
auch das risiko von long beach symptomen
reduzieren darauf weisen die erste
studienergebnisse aus israel hin das
heißt selbst wenn man sich trotz impfung
mit sauerstoff infiziert und auch
erkrankt können langzeitfolgen offenbar
verhindert werden
mit novak suite steht jetzt ein weiterer
impfstoff zur verfügung ein protein
basierter impfstoff ich hoffe dass
dieser impfstoff ein anreiz für viele
unentschlossen ist sich doch noch impfen
zu lassen und dass es gelingt die
impfquote weiter zu steigern für
gesundheitlich gefährdete gruppen
empfiehlt die stiko inzwischen eine
zweite auffrischimpfung das sind
menschen über 70 immungeschwächte
personen
ab 5 jahre bewohnerinnen und bewohner
von pflegeeinrichtungen sowie personen
mit einem risiko für einen schweren
krankheitsverlauf in einrichtungen der
eingliederungshilfe
die zweite auffrischimpfung sollte für
diese gruppe frühestens drei monate
nach der ersten auffrischimpfung
erfolgen und zwar mit einem impfstoff
eine zweite auffrischimpfung wird auch
für mitarbeitende in medizinischen
einrichtungen und pflegeheimen empfohlen
sie sollten die zweite auffrischimpfung
aber frühestens sechs monate nach der
ersten aufregung erhalten
bitte nehmen sie alle diese
möglichkeiten wahl lassen sie sich
impfen und auffrischen damit schützen
sie sich und andere und je mehr menschen
eine immunität gegen kuwait 19 haben
desto besser kommen wir durch diese und
auch durch zukünftige co at 19 wählen
mit denen wir leider rechnen müssen die
impfung ist der beste und der sicherste
weg zur immunität
sehr geehrte damen und herren meine
beiden vorredner haben zu recht auf die
bedeutung der eben von hingewiesen und
das kann man nur uneingeschränkt
unterschreiben es macht sinn sich impfen
zu lassen auch nach einer nikon
infektion damit sie mein gespür dafür
bekommen was wir bisher an impfungen in
deutschland
durchgeführt haben die praxis alleine
haben über 83 millionen impfung
durchgeführt
allerdings stellen wir fest dass seit
einigen wochen die nachfrage deutlich
nachlässt das hat verschiedene gründe
einige sind schon genannt worden wir
hatten beispiele sind der letzten woche
noch knapp 800.000 impfungen davor war
es noch knapp eine million das geht also
jede woche etwas runter deshalb ist das
angebot in den praxen sozusagen von
reinen impfsprechstunden auch wieder
etwas zurückgefahren worden und im
moment sind es noch 56.000 praxen die an
dem kampfgeschehen teilnehmen in der
spitze waren es 83.000 vertragsärztinnen
und vertragsärzte die in deutschland
geimpft haben und 100000 niedergelassen
haben sich beteiligt und die gesagt
diese zahl von über 83 millionen
durchgeführt sehen sie es mir nach dass
ich darauf hinweise dass die apotheken
bis zu 14.000 impfungen in gänze
durchgeführt haben der neue impfstoff
nowaks wird möglicherweise noch einen
kleinen schub bringen für die die bisher
dem mma impfstoff
zurückhaltend gegenüber standen da gibt
es jetzt eine erste lieferung die an die
länder geht dann werden wir ab dem
zweiten quartal glaube ich mit deutlich
mehr dosen rechnen können insofern
hoffen wir dass das in den praxen das
geschehen wieder etwas belebt
problematisches für all diesen
impfstoffen dass sie eben in größeren
gebinden kommen auch bei nova wachsens
zehn dosen pro impfstoff weil was dann
auch relativ schnell verimpft werden
muss das sind probleme die wir von den
impfstoffen kennen und ich gehe davon
aus wir werden perspektivisch kleinere
dosen bekommen das wird aber einfach
noch dauern weil der produktionsprozess
komplett umgebaut werden muss test
geschehen ganz wichtig wenn wir uns das
im internationalen vergleich anschauen
sind wir dabei den pc hardware um 4 auf
100000 einwohner haben wir bei einer
positiven quote von 44 prozent
das heißt nichts anderes als dass wir
eine extrem hohe dunkelziffer haben
sofern die welle scheint gebrochen zu
sein ich hoffe inständig dass das der
fall ist man muss aber glaube ich
realistisch genug sein diese hohe
dunkelziffer einzupreisen wir machen im
moment 73 millionen bürger testung haben
wir durchgeführt 17 millionen für
einrichtungen allein die bürger testung
kosten rund 900 millionen euro
und wenn man dann sieht dass die
aktuellen untersuchung der ludwig
maximilian universität in münchen sagen
dass acht von neun vom die eigentlich
für die vorgängervarianten geprüften
testen konnten nur bei sehr und wir uns
lassen identifizieren können dann stellt
sich natürlich die frage machen diese
bürger testung anlasslos sind oder
sollte man nicht eher eine was bezogene
im festung machen und die dann
gegebenfalls in der pc variante die
einrichtungs bezogene im pflicht ist das
was in nächster zukunft scharf
geschaltet wird das scharf gestellt
werden anführungsstrichen wir haben eine
abfrage macht bei den praxen über 11.000
axams geantwortet und die impfquote bei
den kolleginnen kollegen ist bei 94
prozent extrem hoch das ist schön offen
stand überrascht es mich auch nicht ich
finde es nachvollziehbar und eigentlich
logisch dass man sich einen
medizinischen beruf impfen lässt sollte
kein zweifel schon auch bei dem beim
personal in praxen ist eben sport sehr
hoch trotzdem und das hat uns ein
bisschen verwundert befürchtet
tatsächlich ein drittel der praxen
einschränkungen durch eine sehr rasch
umgesetzt einmal stoff bezogenen pflicht
das überrascht wenn man die impfquoten
sieht hängt aber wahrscheinlich auch mit
regionalen gegebenheiten zusammen
deshalb haben jetzt die bundesländer
diese regionale eben vielleicht ja etwas
sieht man sagen entschärft es geht jetzt
für ein schrittweises vorgehen zur
selbstauskunft der beschäftigen über dem
arbeitgeber der meldet ans
gesundheitsamt dann gibt's danach
rechnungs frist und dann besteht die
möglichkeit das betreten so
beschäftigungsverbot ins gesundheitsamt
da muss man mal schauen was passiert
wichtig ist der auslegung den herbst
minister laut aber hat schon darauf
hingewiesen das war ja nicht die letzte
welle natürlich werden wir nicht
überraschend im herbst ein anstrengendes
infektionsgeschehen zu erleben und nicht
nur von corona auch influenza wird
wieder fröhlichen einzug halten und
deshalb ist es glaube ich wichtig und da
sind wir auch schon eine abstimmung dass
man sich jetzt vorbereitet auf den
herbst wenn möglicherweise auch der
stift bedürfnis wieder steigt mit
steigenden falls ein wetter wird
schlechter
die praxen haben bewiesen dass sie das
in hohen zahlen hinbekommen und ich
glaube wenn wir uns jetzt konzeptionell
festlegen wie wir mit diesen angeboten
im herbst in die praxen geben
idealerweise corona influenza kombiniert
was da geht das ist dann für die
patienten sei klopp formuliert ein
abwasch dann glaube ich kriegen wir hier
sehr schnell auch wieder im griff auf
die möglicherweise an steigenden
fallzahlen finanzierung im stoff liefern
muss stehen ich glaube die impfstoffe
liefern wenn wir bis dahin im griff
haben und ich glaube mit der
finanzierung kriegen war ein
vernünftiges paket geschnürt und lassen
nicht an der stelle noch ein satz zu den
mfs verlieren die praxen sind natürlich
ohne ihre mitarbeitenden nicht in der
lage dieses volumen zu stemmen ohne die
wäre der impfung somit nicht möglich
gewesen wir haben es verschiedentlich
schon getan ich tue es nochmal wir
erachten auch ein durchaus staatlich
finanzierten bonus auch für die ms für
sinnvoll am hoffen dass der gesetzgeber
hier noch mal nachdenkt vielen dank
ich habe eine frage zum
infektionsschutzgesetz brinker die zeit
also wie ist hier fahrplan vielleicht
hänge ich uns das mitteilen
ja vielen dank an spiekermann in der tat
wir arbeiten intensiv daran wir haben
also gestern den ganzen tag gearbeitet
wir werden also in kürze den fraktionen
im deutschen bundestag an entsprechenden
entwurf präsentieren und dann wird dann
die diskussion sofort stattfinden können
aber wir sind noch in der zeit also es
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt gibt es keinen
grund anzunehmen dass hier eine lücke
entstehen könnte zwischen dem auslaufen
der jetzigen regelungen und stand
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt kann man davon
ausgehen dass fast alle infektionen die
wir in deutschland beobachten omikron
infektionen sind und ich hab jetzt die
neuesten also da costa kalenderwoche 6
noch bekommen wo der anteil der ba2 und
damit alles schon deutschlandweit bei
fast 24 prozent liegt somit ist die
einzige frage die ob es also baa1 auf
ba2 ist diese variante per 2 aber das
macht ja für das was ich vorgetragen
habe keinen unterschied in jedem fall
ist es so dass eine zusätzliche impfung
hier einen runden im schutz bietet
übrigens auch wenn man sie vorher gehabt
hat
der kollege meyer von dpa vaart und
zugerichtet habe lauterbach an das ende
der tiefergehenden maßnahmen soll am 20
märz kommen sie erwähnten es welche
kronlage lass mir ihre modellierungen
eigentlich für diesen zeitpunkt erwarten
haben wir dann das sieben tage incidents
von über 1.000 und 10.000 neue fälle und
ab und konnten trotzdem öffnen
ja das ist eine sehr wichtige frage die
schnelle antwort ist können wir zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht genau sagen
also wissen dass br 2 deutlich
ansteckender ist und wenn wir zwei sich
so also weiter verbreitet wie wir es
hier zu sehen anteilig mit einer zunahme
des anteils also von etwa also sechs
prozent pro woche dann kann es sagen
dass zu dem zeitpunkt derzeit bereits
also die die dominierende variante ist
knapp die dominierende variante ist und
dann wurden wir wieder also eine leichte
beschleunigung sehen ob der rückgang der
fälle dann stärker ist als das was wir
zwar dagegen hält das kann man schwer
modellieren das kann sich also kann man
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt sehr schwer
vorhersagen was mir mehr sorgen macht
die ehrlich gesagt ich glaube dass die
fallzahlen zurückgehen werden dass ich
vielleicht also der rückgang
entschleunigt da was mir mehr sorgen hat
ist das was wir wieder vorgetragen hat
und was uns auch im haus bekannt ist wir
sehen eine zunahme der inzidenz bei der
besonders gefährdeten gruppe bei den
über 60 jahren in spa bei den über
70-jährigen somit also kann es durchaus
sein dass die fallzahlen weiter sinken
wie aber stabile oder sogar steigende
todesfälle haben und das ist ja das was
uns besonders besorgen muss das ist dass
es ja kein zustand also das ist ja keine
das ist ja keine wirkliche akzeptable
situation dass jeden tag 200 bis 300
menschen sterben durch eine erkrankung
wie so leicht vermeidbar wäre aber
entschließe ich den zweiten teil der
frage hier nochmal an können wir
trotzdem ganz dem geplanten zeitpunkt
zwanzigster märz öffnen die laufen dann
fehler
maßnahmen aus dass infektionsschutz zu
setzen wird es den ländern ermöglichen
diese maßnahmen dann doch also weiter zu
nutzen sollte das durch die
lage durch die epidemische lage in
diesen ländern notwendig seien somit
also gar nicht einfach davor dass man
glaubt es wäre am 20 märz komplette
öffnung zu erwarten davon gehe ich
selbst nicht aus von der entwicklung die
wir jetzt sehen die fahrzeuge sinken
aber sie sinken langsamer als sie
gestiegen sind es ist einfach unsinn
metrische system
ist einfach zahlen sind sehr schnell
gestiegen sinken jetzt langsamer und
dieser etwas langsamer ab fall der fälle
könnte sich noch verkomplizieren durch
die baa2 variante und durch die
sondersituation dass wir bei den älteren
die besonders schützen
bedürftig sind dass wir dort einen
anstieg der insolvenzen
dann bin ich ja danke herr lauterbach
sie haben ihre bemerkungen begonnen mit
der ukraine und ich hätte gefragt ob es
eigentlich irgendwelche form von hilfe
gibt die auch ihre ministerium oder das
deutsche gesundheitssystem der ukraine
zur verfügung stellen kann gibt es da
irgendwelche überlegungen dass man
entweder mehr verletzte behandelt
medikamente schickt irgendwelche anderen
aspekte der hilfe ist ganz sicher so
dass wir über hilfe maßnahmen die wir
also anbieten können nachdenken da wird
die bundesregierung aber als also
einheit reagieren und daher bitte ich um
verständnis dass ich hier keine also
unabgestimmt und vorschläge vortragen
möchte aber selbstverständlich also ist
hier die humanitäre hilfe gerade im
gesundheitssystem im gesundheitsbereich
von großer bedeutung und darüber wird
viel nachgedacht
können sie uns vielleicht noch eine
zeitliche vorstellungen geben wann die
bundesregierung dann
gemeinsam mit vorschlägen nach draußen
geht es kam nicht zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nicht ich bin dann vor um verständnis
dass gestern und heute
zunächst einmal im vordergrund steht die
beherrschung der lage also dass wir nach
hinten dass wir nachrichtentechnik und
aber auch durch also beratungen mit
entsprechenden also bündnispartnern
erstmal die gesamtlage in den griff
bekommen müssen und daher sind also die
hilfe maßnahmen die definitiv und später
dankbar dass sie sie angesprochen haben
die hilfe maßnahmen die wir also unser
gesundheitssystem leisten kann dass
diese noch nicht also spruchreif sind
noch die daten auch nicht abgestimmt
sind aber sicherlich werden solche
angebote gemacht
wolfs kämpft die hauptstadtstudio fragt
an herrn bieler und sie herr lauterbach
gericht dazu den auffrischungsimpfungen
inzwischen werden vier impfungen
durchgeführt wie werden diese in der
statistik gezählt werden sie extra
ausgewiesen allgemein als
auffrischungsimpfungen gezählt das wende
die kollegin ein könnte dann aber die
prozentzahl der geposteten und verzehren
oder werden sie gar nicht extra
aufgeführt
ja das kann ich gerne beantworten also
wir haben wir einen impf der sport und
werden wir auch einen täglichen bericht
und ich habe mir gerade den gibt's jeden
tag von der website herunterzuladen das
stehen die ja da steht ja welche
impfungen gemacht wurden ob sie
vollständig gemacht wurden mit ihm
auffrischimpfungen die sind also alle
nachlesbar das ist so transparent und
bleibt auch so transparent bislang ist
also da gibt es eigentlich keine
änderung aus meiner sicht
ich bleibe noch mal digital bei den
kollegen holstein
von apotheke adhoc
sie herr lauterbach gerichtet bei ihrem
ersten auftritt in der
bundespressekonferenz haben sie
angekündigt die masken des ihres
vorgängers zu prüfen welche erkenntnisse
über unregelmäßigkeiten gibt es er führt
als beispiele auf e mix von docmorris
oder sind wie bill das bmg zur weiteren
aufklärung beitragen ja dazu kann ich
nur sagen die prüfungen laufen finden
statt die materie ist sehr komplex
also es ist genauso wie bei meinen
ersten auftritt beschrieben wir arbeiten
dort
mit den also interessierten behörden
aber auch mit journalisten die sich
interessieren zusammen es ist aber zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt noch nicht da also
aufklärungs stand erreicht der es mir
erlauben würde
genaueres zu sagen die finanzierung ein
eindruck an dieser aufklärung stand
erreicht sein könnte sehr schwer zu
sagen also in der daten ist nicht nur
die materie komplex sondern also ich war
selbst wenn ich das so sagen darf
überrascht welchen umfang also diese
beschaffungs schwierigkeiten offenbar
damals gehabt haben und auch wie viele
sie haben ein vergleichsverfahren
anhängig zählen von daher bitte ich um
verständnis dass ich beim laufen oder
prüfung mich dann nicht mehr einlassen
kann
ja ich hätte zwei fragen außerhalb von
corona und zwar zur gkv finanzen auf
halt ist ja dass die auch kein sehr
hohen fehlbetrag eingefahren hat mit
über 4,1 milliarden euro das ist ja eine
hausnummer kann das ein anhaltspunkt
dafür sein dass es umbuchten im rsa gibt
an sehr lauterbach und vielleicht noch
die nächste frage direkt dazu wird in
dieser legislatur die lange verschobene
geo er reformen angegangen
zunächst also der das defizit der euro
kann muss also präzise untersucht werden
ob es dort also eine unwucht im rsa
gegeben hat was ich zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt wichtig war es aber dass wir
im rahmen der finanzplanung die jetzt
also man fängt dann feststellen dass es
ein großes strukturelles defizit in der
gkv gibt ein sehr großes defizit ergibt
und also darüber wird auch derzeit
intensiv im haus gesprochen also was zum
beispiel möglichkeiten wären um diesem
defizit zu begegnen sowie zusätzliche
mittel generiert werden können also was
also diskutiert wird sehr intensiv
sprechen wir darüber wie es das defizit
entstanden welche beschlüsse sind da
maßgeblich gewesen wo sind also
möglichkeiten dem also bis zu begegnen
also wie verteilt sich das defizit sich
nicht kassenarten einzelnen kassen all
das wird jetzt hat sehr intensiv geprüft
und werden wir weiter sind wir sind wir
berichten
reform also da bin ich also im gespräch
mit der bundesärztekammer das ist gar
keine frage dass es aber im moment keine
priorität
ihnen ist ja bekannt dass wir also
im koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben
dass also reformen die das zusammenspiel
von gesetzlicher krankenversicherungen
und privater krankenversicherung
betreffen also das so soll von solchen
reformen in dieser legislaturperiode
also versorgung davon abstand nehmen
werden und daher ist für mich noch nicht
ganz klar ob er die reform überhaupt
angehen ja oder nein und wann würde aber
dass auch das ist also also gegenstand
von diskussionen diese diskussionen
finden im haus statt haben wir gestern
ist wieder darüber gesprochen wenn da
mehr klar ist würde ich berichten
der kollege kreutzfeldt von der tat
fragt haben gassen sie haben im
vergangenen september ein ende aller
corona samen für ende oktober gefordert
sind sie der bundesregierung im
nachhinein dankbar dass nicht auf sie
gehört wurde es ist auch ich lebe das
phänomen das man gerne verkürzt und
falsch zitiert wird deshalb will ich das
gerne zum wiederholten mal noch mal
sagen die diskussion war damals analog
zur zum vorgehen in vielen anderen
europäischen staaten noch forum ikon das
muss man der stelle deutlich sagen und
die war auch dahin abzielen dass man mit
einem vorlauf die impfquote noch
verbessert insofern ist das schnee von
gestern
werden möglicherweise noch andere
varianten erleben die uns noch erneut
zum umdenken und ich hoffe dass es
eigentlich eher in die richtung weiter
gewebes bisher haben anstecken aber
nicht so gefährlich und dann werden wir
sehen was über den sommer passiert
herr geinitz von der faz fragt zum
pflege rettungsschirm deutschland locker
hat aber der rettungsschirm für die
pflegeheime wird abermals verlängert
über den märz hinaus warum ist das nötig
werden hier die heime nicht unnötig mit
steuer und beitragsgeldern
subventionierte
ja die pflege haben die
pflegeeinrichtungen haben erhebliche
einnahmeverluste gehabt und mehrausgaben
und die mehrausgaben sind jetzt auch
noch notwendig ich hatte eben also also
über das infektionsschutzgesetz
gesprochen habe noch darüber darauf
hingewiesen dass wir natürlich erhöhte
hygienestandards in den magazinen und
bemühten schutzkleidung masken natürlich
und auch die die arbeitsabläufe sind
dann natürlich durch den durch den also
bestimmt stunden schutzstatus also
verlangsamt somit also ist alles so
personalintensiver teurer schwerer und
dazu kommt dass also auch viele
pflegebedürftige
von pflegeleistungen abstand genommen
haben zum beispiel von der tagespflege
haben viele menschen abstand genommen
weil sie gedacht haben das nicht
möglicherweise infizieren somit also ist
hier der also ein schutzschirm für die
pflegeeinrichtungen ist weiter notwendig
und ich sehe auch ehrlich gesagt was die
fallzahlen angeht und hast hier
angekommen war ja dann gibt und die
situation gerade bei älteren
angezählt keinen grund zu einer neuen
bewertung zu kommen es wurde ja eben von
den wieder schon darauf hingewiesen und
ich teile diese einschätzung wir sehen
wieder mehr ausbrüche und auch
todesfälle in pflegeeinrichtungen
das wollen wir das wollen wir nicht noch
beschleunigen
sie war nie vom er in de fragt zum
pflege bonus an es gibt enttäuschung
über die von ihnen vorgelegten eckpunkte
für den für einen pflege bonus wird es
eine aufstockung geben also es gibt zum
einen also enttäuschung zum anderen aber
auch also zustimmung und man muss darauf
hinweisen es ist eine milliarde euro die
wir hier zur verfügung stellen und dazu
kommt die steuerbefreiung die wir ja
auch bringen in dem sinn ich bin ja ein
einvernehmen mit finanzminister lindner
dass wir hier auch so eine entlastung
der pflegekräfte
bewirken wollen die also boni bekommen
haben die über den eigentlichen veh
geborenes hinausgehen beispielsweise von
den einrichtungen oder von den ländern
somit haben wir hier im prinzip vier
elemente wir haben dann eigentlich und
pläne bulls die eine milliarde euro dann
haben wir die steuerbefreiung dieser
milliarde euro mit abgaben dann haben
wir also die
bonifikationen durch die länder und
durch die einrichtungen und die
steuerbefreiung dies auf einen
komponenten auch und wenn man das alles
zusammen sieht dann ist das deutlich
mehr als eine milliarde und dann ist es
auch in der regel wenn ich gespräche
führe so dass dann schon mal der
enthusiasmus etwas größer wird man darf
uns nicht unterschätzen natürlich hätten
wir lieber also eine größere summe zur
verfügung aber es wird über alles
verhandelt zum jetzigen zeitpunkt sind
wir gebunden an die eine milliarde die
im koalitionsvertrag also oder die im
rahmen der vorstellung des
koalitionsvertrags also
geschossen wurde ich schließe jetzt dazu
noch eine andere frage digitalen dann
bin ich bei ihnen frau spielern haben
nochmal am maibaum vom deutschen
ärzteblatt zum cola bonus an bis wann
das vorliegende eckpunktepapier
finalisiert wird also er fragt nach dem
zeitplan und ob es für die medizinischen
fachangestellten die vorher auch schon
angesprochen waren aus ihrer sicht auch
einen bonus geben wird ob diese einen
bonus erhalten sollen also das
eckpunktepapier ist fertig und mein haus
ist jetzt dabei einen entsprechenden
referentenentwurf zu formulieren dieser
referentenentwurf wird jetzt also sehr
schnell zirkulieren wir wollen auf jeden
fall erreichen dass zum beginn der
zweiten jahreshälfte der bonus
ausgezahlt wird und das ist auf der
grundlage unserer zeitplanung ist das
auch haltbar die medizinischen
fachangestellten ihm zb praxen aber
nicht nur dort sind zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt nicht vorgesehen weil wir
singen konzentrieren wollen auf die
pflege und da bitte ich um verständnis
ich glaube trotzdem darauf hinweisen
dass ich die arbeit die von denen also
fachangestellten geleistet worden ist
gerade in der impfkampagne dass es
dieses jahr zu würdigen weiß das hat
aber auch schon eine rolle gespielt bei
der frage wie gut also vergüten wie er
eigentlich die impfung und
wenn man jetzt den internationalen
vergleich heranzieht ist die vergütung
von 28 euro pro impfung
nicht also
wie ist diese vergütung nicht schlecht
im vergleich trotzdem möchte ich noch
mal ausdrücklich
gesagt haben ich würdige die leistung
der praxis unter fachangestellten in den
praxen aus möglich damit verspielte man
herr professor sie haben gerade schon
erwähnt diversen informationsquellen wie
das lka auf den seiten bietet ich wusste
ganz klar die impfquote welche
fehlerquote ist von welcher fehlerquote
ist momentan
fünf
also zunächst einmal muss man sagen dass
die impfquoten natürlich auch eine
schätzung darstellen ja und die
impfquoten die herausforderung vor der
wir stehen ist ja folgende wir erhalten
ja von den niedergelassenen hausärzten
erhalten wir keine einzelfall basierten
daten sondern nur sogenannte
aggregierten daten
das heißt dass man nicht genau zuordnen
kann welche personen welchen impfstoff
erhalten hat das aber das ist ja schon
lange bekannt dass beruht auf der krone
in finsdorf vororten glaube ich heißt
sie und das heißt das macht uns das
leben natürlich nicht so einfach
wir werden das aber darüber korrigieren
oder oder präzisieren können dass wir
dann irgendwann die ab- oder nicht
irgendwann sondern wären wir schon
abrechnungsdaten von den
kassenärztlichen vereinigungen
das sind ja immer quartalsweise
abrechnungsdaten damit können wir dann
das genauer zuordnen wir haben
schätzungen durchgeführt wir führen ja
weil wir auch wussten dass wir diese
daten nicht einzelfall basiert sondern
nur aggregiert von den hausärzten
bekommen führen wir ja auch
untersuchungen durch befragungs
untersuchungen durch diese cosimo studie
die kennen sie ja vielleicht und daraus
ergibt sich ja immer ein gewisses delta
und das ist aber eine befragung und in
einer befragung wissen wir dass es
natürlich auch dort verzerrungen gibt
weil natürlich menschen die mitmachen
dort sind menschen die hauptsächlich
mehr der impfung zu sprechen als
diejenigen die das nicht tun und
insofern hatten wir bei den befragungen
teilweise etwa fünf prozent höhere
zahlen aber wir haben das ja dann
umgerechnet über die anzahl der
ausgelieferten ist das heißt also es
wird ein mittelwert seien 23 prozent
etwa aber ich möchte es noch mal sagen
das sind ja schätzungen und diese
schätzungen geben wir auch in unserem
bericht insofern hat sich an diesen
schätzungen nichts geändert das heißt
also wir haben nach wie vor und sie
können ja auf den wochenbericht gucken
dass stena die impfquoten genau drauf
wir haben nach wie vor etwa 175 oder 76%
grundimmunisierung da hat sich nichts
daran geändert an den zahlen die sind
genauso korrekt und geschätzt wie sie es
seit wochen sind wir kommen gleich zwei
nachfrage
vielleicht ergänzend also herr wieder
ist ja schon gesagt melden ja doppelt
die praxen und zwar tagesaktuell werden
die impfstoffe gemeldet auch die
altersgruppen männlich weiblich erst
zweite impfung das wird alles jeden tag
gemeldet insofern gibt es da minimale
fehlerquoten wie groß die nato am ende
des tages sein können kann ich nicht
beurteilen in der auswertung zu den
detailgetreuen meldungen die im rahmen
der abrechnung erfolgen gab es wohl
bislang ich hoffe dass das aus
mittlerweile glaube ich aus grundannahme
probleme seitens des lka weil es keine
schnittstelle gab wo diese daten
elektronisch gemeldet werden konnten da
wird natürlich patienten individuell
präzise gemeldet wie das bei impfungen
üblich ist wir haben damals im absprung
mit minister sparen diese tagesaktuelle
meldung und ob gemacht um eben genau so
eine art
sowie jens zu haben was die menge der
impfung an gewinn so fern ist er wert
und das haben wir überprüft es gibt da
ganz minimale fehlermeldung oder unter
meldungen die zum teil über die
wochenend impfung erklärbar sind finden
diese impfung einig um diese meldung
tagesgenau statt insofern sollte das
ich verstehe nicht was immer alles so
diskutiert wird aber ich hab schon nicht
im griff sie sehen ich bin wieder
gekommen tut mir leid das nächste mal
letztes mal auf grund eines arztbesuches
nicht dabei sein konnte was worüber
sollen wir sonst sprechen ja also wir
wir sind hier nach wie vor dabei eine
pandemie zu bekämpfen und das ist doch
das entscheidende
lassen sie uns doch über die maßnahmen
sprechen über die wichtigen maßnahme um
eine pandemie zu bekämpfen
was soll ich mir dazu sagen also ich
kann die berichterstattung nicht
beeinflussen sie ist wie sie ist und wir
tun alles um möglichst sachlich und
nüchtern seit zwei jahren und nun glaube
ich zwei monaten über diese pandemie zu
berichten und das wird auch so bleiben
es gibt digitale 22 nachfragen zu
schonen angesprochenen themen die
kollegin mißlbeck vom erz
nachrichtendienst fragt nochmal nach
nach der geo und fragt an sie herr
gassen zu den ebenen getätigten
äußerungen von herrn lauterbach was sie
dazu sagen wie sie wissen ist die gop
nicht mein originärer berührt ich bin ja
für die versorgung der gesetzlich
versicherten patienten verantwortlich
folglich für den ebm
ich habe das jetzt zur kenntnis genommen
dass die beg das ist ja auch das gebiet
der bundesärztekammer die geo jetzt
verhandelt die ist ja so weit auch
vorhanden ist jetzt die frage und ich
glaube das ist eher eine einordnung ob
das eine eine strukturreform im bereich
das verhältnis gesetzt privater krank
was ich an darstellt oder eben einfach
eine gebührenanpassung die an dem
grundsätzlichen system der pkv gkv ist
insofern ist das glaube ich eine
bewertung die die bundesregierung
vornehmen muss ob das sozusagen bereits
eine strukturelle grundlegende
entscheidung über annäherung oder nicht
annäherung von gesundheitssystem ist
oder einfach eine aktualisierung einer
seit 1996 nicht angepassten privaten
gebührenordnung für immerhin zehn
millionen bundesbürger
und frau wolfskin vom ard fragt man dazu
der für tim cook in der statistik nach
ihres wissens nach das kann ich jetzt
von dieser stelle aus nicht überprüfen
wird nicht ausgewiesen ob es sich um
eine erste oder zweite
auffrischungsimpfung handelt und das
macht einen unterschied für den status
wenn die zählung der vierten impfung
allgemein als auffrischung dann zu einem
scheinbar höheren anteil angeboten führt
dann kann ich die frage nicht
beantworten ich nehme sie noch mal mit
wenn das so ist und berichtet dann beim
nächsten mal was machen klappt es dann
offensichtlich ich kann nicht mehr dazu
sagen als ich eben sagt das gibt dann
bin ich jetzt nicht informieren obwohl
das ja auch den impfstatus keine
auswirkung hat wenn sie dreimal den
handel sehen wir keinen besseren im
status formal mit mehr freiheit also
dreimal kämpfen ist ja wer eine
individuelle
sinnhaftigkeit und es gibt mittlerweile
ein zusätzliches geld das aber ich denke
auch das problem ist jetzt nichts
verkaufen
die kollegen interessiert sich trotzdem
dafür im dann komme ich zu dem kollegen
von der bild zeitung an herrn lauterbach
und herrn gassen die 60 millionen euro
teure werbekampagne impfen schützt der
bundesregierung ist nun seit mehr als
drei wochen bekannt seither ist die zahl
der wöchentlichen impfungen von 3,4 auf
unter eine million gefallen ist die
kampagne gescheitert
ich persönlich kann nicht einschätzen
wie stark die kampagne wird wurde sie
aber nicht als gescheitert betrachten
was es ja eine relativ kurze zeit phase
über die wir hier reden
und ich finde die kampagne gut gemacht
sie ist durch spezialisten vorbereitet
worden da keine frage ich tue sich aber
schwer ob der grundlage dass wir im
moment sind die situation haben wo viele
menschen glauben die auch mikron
variante verhandlung sun wiederum andere
glauben dass die omikron infektion
bester schütze aus dem funk und wiederum
andere glauben dass man auf die auch
also auf den umweg von impfstoff war
müsse um sich irgendwann zu lassen das
sind die drei gründe die im vordergrund
stehen und da tut sich jede auch noch so
gut gemacht also impfkampagne tut sich
da schwer ich glaube dass das im
vordergrund steht
ist es glaube ich immer schwierig den
den effekt einer impfkampagne zu
beachten wenn sie werber frage werde
ihnen sagen wir hatten enormen effekt
wenn sie endverbraucher sind ist es
wahrscheinlich weil es immer ein
bisschen ungefähren letztlich muss da
der köder dem fisch schmecken ich kann
es nicht beurteilen wir haben glaube ich
tatsächlich mit rahmendaten ein bisschen
zu kämpfen die diese impfkampagne oder
bewerbung dann auch nicht wirklich
aufbricht
von da ich kann es wirklich nicht
beurteilen diese erweiterte fragen
[Musik]
sie haben noch nicht an oder ist es
schon angeleuchtet ist ja okay alles
klar anno fricke ärzte zeitung haben
jetzt alle könnten sie noch mal deutlich
sagen wie im bundestag gerade die
stimmung und das
verhältnis zur allgemeine impfpflicht
ist die apparaten wird
also
meine einschätzung ist die dass die
mehrheit der abgeordneten im deutschen
bundestag eine allgemeine impfpflicht
wünscht das ist mein eindruck von
gesprächen die geführt werden und also
von rückmeldungen die ich bekomme ja mal
was sehr schwierige situation
indem wir wesentlichen drei anträge
haben die an impfpflicht also
sinnvoll finden abstufungen zum allen
der antrag also von dagmar schmidt und
jana starben und anderen für die pflicht
ab 18 dann also der antrag für die
impfpflicht ab 50 von ulmann
unter anderem und dann wenn also der
antrag der union der unionsfraktion wo
es also man endlich gibt die also später
kommen soll wenn sie gebraucht wird alle
drei anträge also sind im prinzip für
eine nebenpflicht aber unter
unterschiedlichen bedingungen ist das
aussuchen somit also was positiv
ausdrücken wir haben eine mehrheit im
haus für eine nebenpflicht das kann aber
sein dass nachher so die situation
schwierig ist ich glaube dass es daher
sehr wichtig ist dass wir die anträge
zusammen bringen die für die allgemeine
impfpflicht sind also dass wir also uns
überlegen also vielleicht dann doch also
den antrag ullmann den antrag das mache
ich mit so zusammenzubringen dass ein
einzelner eintrag ist weil die kleinen
unterschiede dürften nicht die große
gemeinsamkeit nachher verunmöglichen und
vielleicht kann man auch noch mit der
union ins gespräch kommen
da gibt es ja auch nicht alles was die
union jetzt vorschlägt in dieser
hinsicht ist unsinnig somit hoffe ich
noch immer dass wir einen gemeinsamen
beschluss nach erschaffen dafür muss
geworden sind ich glaube dass die
allgemeine impfpflicht nicht
parteipolitisch diskutiert werden sollte
das passiert ich für einen großen fehler
und ich jetzt so ein wie auch kollege
gassen ist eben vorgetragener wir werden
im herbst wieder probleme haben das
wetter wird schlechter dann ist die
frage kommt die omikron variante noch
mal zurück vielleicht da2 vielleicht
eine weitere variante der super jan
subtyp des
oder eine ganz andere variante ich
spreche mit vielen wissenschaftlern
darüber international also auch
außerhalb von deutschland die sich dann
mit der gleichen fahrrad beschäftigen
und
offen gesagt habe ich noch bisher keinen
renommierten wissenschaftler gesehen
dass ich es mit sauerstoff lange
beschäftigt und auch mit seiner
varianten entwicklung beschäftigt wie
gesagt hätte im herbst kommt nichts mehr
im herbst also ist es vorbei dann könnte
noch ein paar leute omikron aber das
war's dann nach zwei jahren zweieinhalb
jahren ist es vorbei kommen die diesel
also rückmeldung fehlt mir noch also das
sagt mir eigentlich keine alle sagen
eigentlich also da kommt wieder eine
neue variante oder ohne comcom zurück
und wenn dem so wäre bräuchten wir
natürlich eine viel höhere impfquote art
wie sie haben ich möchte daher
verhindern dass wir im herbst in einer
situation sind wo wir uns gegenseitig
die schuld zuweisen
weshalb wir keine impfpflicht haben und
dann möglicherweise einschränkungen
wieder beschließen müssen möglicherweise
sogar einschränkungen für unsere kinder
beschließen wenn es den einschränkungen
also für die gastronomie möglicherweise
beschließen müssen so viele dinge die
dann wieder in diskutiert werden müssen
und dann ging es dann hin und her dann
wird dann also diskutiert jetzt aber
kann eben pflicht ist hat die spd schuld
weil es keinen regierungsentwurf gab
oder dann wird diskutiert also hat
geschmerzt schuld weil er also seinen
abgeordneten die beteiligung an der
gewissensentscheidung
also verboten hat oder hat die fdp
schuld weil herr kubicki beispielsweise
keine impfpflicht will oder was dann
käme dann also dieses der bürger so
furchtbar findet und ehrlich gesagt
viele politiker mir angefangen diese
schuldzuweisung die hätten wir dann
wieder wir werden dann in diesem spiel
der schulzeit zu weisen wer hat die
schuld am versagen dass wir die
impfpflicht nicht hinbekommen haben
obwohl der bundestag keine mehrheit
hatte und die bevölkerung eigentlich
auch das möchte das will ich verhindern
und daher glaube ich dass wir wenn eine
zusammenarbeit müssen schaffen so es
gibt jetzt am inn anschluss doch
nachfragen in war dann bin ich bei herrn
trinken beim zweiten auto brach ich ganz
gern nach dem anderen das bag gefragt in
deutschland ist ja auch g7 vorsitzland
im moment und es gibt jetzt wieder neue
internationale bemühungen die kovacs in
impfinitiative
anders zu finanzieren auszuweiten zu
beschleunigen hätte ganz gern gewusst ob
deutschland da über das hinaus was es im
moment leistet auch einen neuen
substanziellen beitrag beisteuern ja ich
verhandle auf jeden fall mit dem
generaldirektor der
weltgesundheitsorganisation aber auch
mit den organisationen die kovacs
unterstützen also zb für die also
schnelle impfstoffentwicklung gabi für
den einkauf von impfstoff
mengen
für die koordinierung der abgabe der
impfstoffe und kovacs selbst aber auch
mit dem wellcome trust von anderen
stiftungen bin ich im gespräch darüber
was kann man aus der pandemie lernen das
hat ist ein großer schwerpunkt meiner
arbeit also ich möchte wirklich
tatsächlich in diesem jahr wo wir die
sieben vorsitz haben möchte ich also
mich beteiligen an also den bewegungen
aus panama etwas zu lernen für die
nächste pandemie dazu zählen andere
abläufe dazu zählt auch also eine
also so genannte preparedness initiative
dass man in den ländern wo mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit neue viren entstehen
also besser vorbereitet ist und dort
also vor ort schon entsprechende
fachkräfte hat hast du zählt allerdings
auch natürlich die bewältigung der
panini die noch läuft und da hat
deutschland mit den 175 millionen
impfeinheiten die wir zur verfügung
stellen wollen also mehr an größeren
beitrag also angekündigt als er der
größe unseres landes entsprechend würde
also wir tun mehr als andere und ich war
es auch darauf hin dass ich von dass wir
von diesen 175 millionen schon also ich
glaube über 120 millionen gespendet
haben das heißt wir sind hier weil vor
der zeit und es wird sicherlich auch
intensiv darüber gesprochen werden wie
allgemein die finanzierungen der whu
verändert werden kann auch zum beispiel
der
antrag der länder im sinne also festen
länder zuweisungen ob dieser antrag
erhöht werden kann oder nicht da also
finden in den nächsten wochen und
monaten intensive gespräche statt an
denen ich mich federführend beteiligen
darf ich kurz nachfragen es gibt
gerüchte dass deutschland noch mal bei
kovacs einen großen betrag zusätzlichen
betrag beisteuern würde stimmt das ich
würde einfach also abwarten wollen wie
die dinge sich entwickeln das engagement
was wir für kovacs haben ist erheblich
und
ich glaube dass wir da schon mehr getan
haben als andere länder aber noch mehr
tun werden dann hat die letzte frage
verbauen ja ich wollte auf die
ausführungen noch einmal eingehend vor
hin zum thema impfen warum geben sie
eigentlich nicht zu ihr professor
lauterbach dass es ein riesenfehler der
regierung war das ganze verfahren jetzt
so ablaufen zu lassen sie müssen sich
jetzt kümmern und alle arme ausreichen
um irgendwelche mehrheiten zu kriegen
damit die im flur steht seit zwei jahren
wird gesagt dass impfen holt aus der
pandemie wir sind haft impfen ist wissen
wir alle und lassen das trotzdem wird so
laufen kein wunder dass es jetzt
wahrscheinlich vor die wand fährt also
warum hat die regierung nicht gesagt wir
machen das zum ganz klaren gesetzentwurf
und fertig aus das problem heute nicht
ja das ist ja was ich eben sagte was mir
missfällt und was uns keinen millimeter
weiter bringt dass wir also uns gedanken
machen wie wir schuld zuweisen
ich finde es einfach interessant an der
lösung des problems zu arbeiten und so
ob es wirklich also hier
erfolgreicher gewesen wäre ein mit einem
regierungsantrag zu arbeiten oder nicht
und das also ist ja reine spekulation
das also ist
durch nichts belegt in dem sinne die
entscheidung ist jetzt so getroffen dass
das also ein also ein beschluss des
bundestags an wird das auch gut begründe
aber also eine gewissensentscheidung die
hier zu treffen ist also die körperliche
unversehrtheit wird ja hier eingeschenkt
und von daher ist es gut zu begründen
gewesen und ich schaue einfach nach
vorne und also versuchen auch etwas
hinzubekommen
das nicht dass jetzt keine kritik an
ihnen sie an ihrer arbeit nach aber ich
will es mal so sagen in deutschland
haben wir sehr viele leute zu jedem
zeitpunkt wo man sich so auch in wendet
man findet immer welche die gut darin
sind also zu erklären deshalb etwas
nicht funktioniert und wer schuld hat es
gibt zu wenige die versuchen ein problem
zu lösen
dann lassen wir es aber wenden vielen
dank vielen dank dass sie wieder unsere
gäste waren und uns rede und antwort
standen und einen hoffentlich guten
wochenausklang in diesen krisenzeiten
dankeschön